welcome back where's Eman we have a
great show tonight right Andy laughs I'm
serious whatever anyway I want to talk
about something tonight we do this
occasionally on the show we do a comedy
bit with our prop master bill tall
there's a picture boom and that photo
really captures Bill's
stellar personality yeah sure that's
good soup what soup what are you talking
about
why not
okay well I said we do the same with
Bill where he shows us exactly what he's
gonna do and but you have to make sure
it's New England clam chowder not that
red kind whatever you call that red kind
any what the hell are you talking about
I mean come on who orders soup with
hooters
okay Jeff Jeff what's wrong with Andy
and he's a repeat
Andy's a repeat yeah today's Andy had to
run to the dentist during the commercial
break so this Andy is a rerun from the
October 15th 2014 show what he's a rerun
Andy I didn't know he could do that you
know my son's a teenager but god bless
him he still loves carving pumpkins Jeff
how am I supposed to do this show with
Eddie saying random crap from six months
ago
Jeff Jeff who is the first guest on
October 15th
Chelsea Handler this is ridiculous I
can't do a show like this I'm calling
Andy at the dentist yeah hey Andy hey
yeah we need you to come back now your
rerun isn't working out so well which
one are you running the one from October
15th oh is that the night that I
insulted Chelsea Handler well it might
be that cast iron heart of yours yeah
Andy yeah you started making out then
yeah you better get back here right now
get back here Andy Conan what do you
want please make yourself stop as my
reruns started taking his clothes off
yet make him stop there he goes
took my Dennis back his shotgun thanks a
lot
you